Quran
has the solution
for prostitution, for adultery, for
fornication.
Allah says in the Quran in surah isra
chapter number 17 verse number 32, come
not close to adultery, to zena, it is an
evil opening other roots to evil.
Quran has a solution for obscinity,
for shamelessness.
The hijab is mentioned in the Quran in
surah nur chapter number 24 verse number
30 and 31. First Allah talks about the
hijab for the man then of the woman.
Allah says in surah nur chapter 24 verse
number 30 say to the believing man
that he should lower his gaze and guard
his modesty. Whenever a man looks at a
woman and if any brazen thought any
understanding thought comes he should
lower his gaze. The next verse talks
about the hijab for the woman. Say to
the believing woman that she should
lower a G and guard her modesty and
display not a beauty except for appears
ordinary off except in front of husband,
her father, her son and a big list of
man is given. And there are six basic
criterias for hijab. The first is the
extent which differs between the man and
the woman. For the man from the navl to
the knee. For the woman the complete
body should be covered. The only part
that can be seen are the face and the
hands up to the wrist. Some scholars say
they should be covered. The remaining
five criteria are the same that the
clothes they wear should not be tight
fitting so that it reveals the figure.
Third, it should not be transparent or
translucent so that you can see through.
Number four, it should not be glamorous
so that it attracts the opposite sex.
Number five, it should not resemble that
of the other religions. And number six,
it should not resemble that of the
opposite sex. You know today the western
world talking about woman liberalization
it is nothing but a disguised form of
degrading the woman of exploitation of a
body degradation of a soul
in the name of art and culture they're
degrading our mothers our sisters Quran
has the solution
for the economic problem
today one of the major
cause of economic problem is ribba his
interest and Allah says uses the word
ribba in no less than eight places and
Allah says in surah bakar chapter 2 vers
278 and 279 that those who give up not
the demands of ribba of interest take
notice of a war from Allah and his
rasool means if you involve in ribba in
interest Allah and his rasool will wage
a war against you and drinking alcohol
is a major sin but no worse says that
Allah and his rasool will wage a war
against you. But Allah says if you're
involved in ribba besides being a major
sin, Allah and his rasool will wage a
war against you.
So the solution for the economic problem
of the world is abstain from ribba,
abstain from interest.
Quran
has the solution of corruption. Allah
says in surah bakar chapter 2 verse
number 18 188 that use not your wealth
as bait to judges in order to eat other
people's wealth or bribing is private in
Islam. Quran
has the solution for the political
problems for the psychological problem
for the social problems for the economic
problems of the world. Quran has the
solution for your personal problems, for
the problems of your family, for the
problems of your society, for the
problem of your country, for the problem
of the whole world.
For any book to claim that it is the
last and final revelation of God,
it should pass the test of time.
Previously
was the age of miracles and
alhamdulillah the glorious Quran is the
miracle of miracles. Then came the age
of science and technology. Then came the
age of literature and poetry and Quran
alhamdulillah is the best Arabic
literature available on the face of the
earth.
And
yes I have one minute I'm aware of it.
[snorts]
[clears throat]
I'm keeping that I'm better than them.
Then but today is not the age of
literature and poetry. Today is the age
of science and technology. So if you
analyze if you compare science with any
other religious book all the book fails
the test except the Quran. Quran passes
the test of science also. And this
inshallah I'll be covering my talk
tomorrow at 8:00. Quran and modern
science compatible or incompatible. And
inshallah today at 3:00 I'll be there'll
be a separate session only for question
answer session with me at 3:00 I'd like
to end my talk with the verse of the
glorious Quran
in surah assur
is chapter 17 verse number which says
when truth is falsehood falsehood
perishes for falsehood it's by its
nature bound to perish